♪ ♪
>> Jesse: PRESIDENT BIDEN IN
MEXICO FOR HIS THREE AMIGOS
SENATE AFTER TAKING HEAT AT THE
BORDER, THE MEETING WITH THE
MEXICAN PRESIDENT AND CANADA'S
PRIME MINISTER, TRYING TO WORK
WITH MEXICO ON STOPPING THE FLOW
OF DEADLY FENNEL THAT IS
POISONING THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS, AND HE IS POSTING
ABOUT PROGRESS AT THE BORDER,
BUT CANNOT EVEN GET SOME BASIC
FACTS RIGHT.
>> ABLE TO DISCUSS THE SHARED
SECURITY INCLUDING THE JOINT
ACTION FOR A PLAGUE OF FENTANYL
KILLING 100,000 IN AMERICAN SO
FAR AND NOW WE CAN TACKLE A
REGULAR MIGRATION WHICH I THINK
WE ARE WELL ON HER WAY TO DOING.
>> Jesse: UNDERSTANDING THE
FENTON ALL DEATHS BY ABOUT
100,000, AND THE LETTER HE GOT
FROM GREG ABBOTT, TURNS OUT HE
DID NOT CARE ENOUGH TO EAT IT.
SPEAK OF THE PRESIDENT IS WELL
AWARE OF THE CONCERNS WITH THE
ESSENTIAL FOR US IN THAT LETTER,
AND KEEPING WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
CONCERNS, AND CLEARLY THEY DON'T
HAVE THE SAME YOU WITH RESPECT
ON HOW TO HANDLE HANDLE AT THE
BORDER.
>> Jesse: SO DID NONCE READ
THE LETTER AND COULD NOT READ
HIS OWN LETTER THAT HE WAS
TRYING TO GET OUT AT THE
MEETING.
>> Dana: I ALWAYS TRY TO LOOK
AT THINGS WITH THE VIEW OF WHAT
IS THE GOOD NEWS?
WHAT IS THE SILVER LINING?
AND I REALLY BEEN A
DISAPPOINTMENT SINCE EVERYBODY,
BUT IN REGARDS TO THE THREE
AMIGOS SUMMIT, YOU THINK
SOMETHING CAN GET DONE, THE
PRESIDENT HAS A MIDTERM BEHIND
THEM COMING HE HAS THE
REELECTION IN FRONT OF THEM,
MAYBE HE WILL WANT TO ADDRESS
THIS, AND THE PET THAT THEY CAN
BE AS IT WAS DISMISSIVE OF THE
GOVERNMENT OF THE STAGE AT THE
FRONT LINE DOING WITH STATE TO
MONEY, WITH HIS STATE TAXPAYER
MONEY HAVING TO DO WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SHOULD BE
DOING AND HE WRITES A LETTER TO
THE PRESIDENT, I UNDERSTAND THAT
IT'S A LITTLE BIT OF A PROP,
RIGHT?
BUT THE MESSAGE WAS THAT I NEED
YOU TO HEAR ME, I THINK THAT
THAT IS ACTUALLY PRETTY RUDE
COMMENT TO TAKE THE LETTER AND
THEN TO HAVE A SPOKESPERSON SAY,
HE DID NOT READ IT, HE BASICALLY
KNOWS WHAT IS THERE, TAKE A
MOMENT TO READ IT AND SOMETIMES
I THINK ABOUT WHY DO YOU EVEN
WANT TO RUN FOR OFFICE?
WHY DO YOU WANT TO BE IN
LEADERSHIP?
PROBABLY BECAUSE HE WANT TO
SOLVE PROBLEMS, SOLVING PROBLEMS
MEANS ADMITTING THERE IS A
PROBLEM, AND NOW THEY HAVE DONE
THE CHECK THE BOX AT THE BORDER,
I THINK THAT JUST CUT YESTERDAY
SAID THE REPUBLICANS ARE MOVING
THE GOALPOST, THEY SAID WHY
DIDN'T YOU GO TO THE BORDER?
AND WE ARE SAYING WE KNOW THAT
THE BORDER VISIT WAS SANITIZED,
DID NOT EVEN TALK TO THE
CONGRESSMAN FROM THE AREA WHO IS
A REPUBLICAN, WHO IS A
REASONABLE GUY, TRYING TO WORK
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION ON
THINGS AND THE ONLY REPUBLICAN
THAT VOTED AGAINST THE HOUSE
REPUBLICAN RULES PACKAGE, TONY
GONZALEZ AND YOU JUST HAVE A
FEELING THAT NOTHING IS GOING TO
CHANGE PRIOR TO THIS VISIT.
THE ONE THING THAT THE PRESIDENT
IT WAS GOOD, AND I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE A LITTLE BIT MORE, BUT THE
PRESIDENT OF MEXICO HAD THE
NERVE TO SAY THAT THE
UNITED STATES HAS DONE NOTHING
FOR LATIN AMERICA AND
SOUTH AMERICA SINCE JFK, AND
THANKFULLY PRESIDENT BIDEN DID
PUSH BACK ON THAT, BECAUSE
AMERICAN TAXPAYERS HAVE DONE A
LOT, ONE OF THE BIG THINGS THAT
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT ROOT
CAUSES, NO ONE IN MEXICO OR
LATIN AMERICA TENDS TO HAVE A
MAYOR I GUESS, BECAUSE THE ROOT
CAUSES ARE STARING AT THEM RIGHT
IN THE FACE.
>> Greg: NOT THE MIRROR THAT
YOU USE.
>> Jesse: YOU GIVE MEXICO THE
MONEY AND IT GOES AND THEN ALL
OF A SUDDEN THE CARTELS HAVE
PROOF.
>> Greg: JOE BIDEN WANTS A
JOB, HE DOES NOT WANT THE WORK,
IT IS BEEN ABOUT THE PERKS, THE
BENEFIT, AND THE STATUS, THE
AVIATOR GLASSES, THE BOMBER
JACKET, HE IS THE INTERNAL
CONSULTANT THAT GETS THE SIX OR
SEVEN FIGURES BUT NEVER DOES ANY
WORK WE ALSO KNOW WHY JOE
FINALLY BROUGHT UP FENTANYL TO
BECAUSE HUNTER FINALLY RAN OUT,
NFL CLASSIC, BUT THE QUESTION IS
WHO IS REALLY MORE CORRUPT, WHO
IS A SELFISH POLITICIAN, THE GUY
WHO WANTED TO BUILD A WALL AT
THE BORDER OR THE ONE WHO WANTS
TO BUILD A WALL AROUND HIS BEACH
HOUSE?
AT LEAST DONALD TRUMP WAS
GETTING MEXICANS TO PAY FOR IT
WHERE JOE BIDEN WILL JUST GET
MEXICANS TO BUILD IT, BUT WE ARE
GOING TO PAY FOR IT, AND THE
REASON HE IS BUILDING THE WALL
IS NOT EVEN FOR SECURITY IT'S TO
KEEP THEM FROM WANDERING OFF
INTO TRAFFIC.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE ON FIRE
TODAY, CLASSIC, YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THIS?
AND IT HAS NOT BEEN A SMOOTH
TRIP.
IT HAS NOT BEEN A SMOOTH TRIP.
>> Harold: I'M NOT HAS
BOTHERED BY HIM NOT TO READING
ABBOTT'S LETTER, WHAT I AM
BOTHERED BY AS I WOULD'VE
THOUGHT THAT THE SUMMIT, WE LAID
OUT ELEMENTS FOR WHAT IT COULD
LOOK LIKE, AND THE TRAFFICKING
OF DRUGS AND HUMANS BE IT SEX
TRAFFICKING, GANGS COMING
ACROSS, THAT'S WHAT I WANT
ANSWERS TO.
MAYBE THERE IS A LOT GOING ON WE
ARE NOT SEEN, I'M GLAD THAT
THERE WAS PUSH BACK, I AM ONE
THAT CALLED FOR HIM AS AN
INVESTMENT, BUT THE PRESIDENT
WAS A MEXICAN PRESIDENT
PRESENTED NOT ONLY WAS NOT
FACTUAL, BUT CERTAINLY WAS NOT
PARTNER-LIKE HIM WHEN HE SAYING,
AND WHAT HE IS TRYING TO GET OUT
AM GLAD THAT OUR PRESIDENT
RESPONDED AS HE DID, WE NEED A
WALL, DEMOCRATS BUILD IT,
REPUBLICANS AGREED TO WHAT WE
HAVE TO DO ON THE OTHER SIDE AS
TRANSPARENCY OF HOW YOU GET THE
CITIZENSHIP AND GIVE OUR
STUDENTS FOR WORKERS AND THOSE
THAT HAVE SPENT FIVE, TEN, 15
YEARS IN AMERICA LOOKING TO
BECOME CITIZENS LET'S FIGURE OUT
SOME NEGOTIATION, BUT IT HAS TO
START WITH TWO PEOPLE AT THE
TOP, PRESIDENT BIDEN AND I THINK
RIGHT BELOW HIM SPEAKER
McCARTHY, THEY ARE IN THE
MAJORITY, THE TWO NEED TO PUSH
REPUBLICANS IN THE HOUSE PUT
FORWARD I THINK A SOUND,
REASONABLE, AND FORCIBLE
IMMIGRATION AND BORDER PLAN,
YOU'RE GOING TO FORCE THE
PRESIDENT AND YOU WILL HAVE
DEMOCRATS LIKE ME SAYING WE HAVE
TO COUNTER.
I THINK YOU HAVE A LOT MORE
DEMOCRATS INCLUDING THE ONES
WITH THE PRESIDENT YESTERDAY AT
THE BORDER.
>> Jesse: I DON'T KNOW IF I
SEE IMMIGRATION REFORM OUT OF
THIS PRESIDENCY?
>> Judge Jeanine: I'M NOT SO
SURE, NUMBER ONE, DO YOU RECALL
THAT THE PRESIDENT GAVE
KAMALA HARRIS THE JOB OF BEING
THE BORDERS ARE AND FINDING THE
ROOT CAUSES?
COULD A FINE LINE TO THAT,
FINE-TUNED IT AND JUST SAY CAN I
TALK TO SOMEONE ACROSS THE
BORDER?
I WANT TO KNOW WHAT THE ROOT
CAUSES ARE AND WHY THESE PEOPLE
ARE COMING FOR US?
HE DID NOT SPEAK TO ANY OF THE
PEOPLE CROSSING THE BORDER AND
COULD HAVE FOUND GOT RID OF THAT
WHOLE ISSUE RIGHT OFF THE BAT,
THAT'S NUMBER ONE, NUMBER TWO,
NO REPUBLICANS WHETHER IT WAS
GONZALEZ OR ANYONE ELSE, WHAT IS
THE PROBLEM WITH MR. UNITY BRING
IN PEOPLE WHO WERE REPUBLICANS
WITH HIM FROM THAT AREA TO WORK
AT THE BORDER, WHAT IS HE AFRAID
OF?
WE ARE GOING TO SAY SOMETHING?
AND THE MOST RUDE AND
CONDESCENDING THING HE DID,
THERE IS A MAN, GOVERNOR ABBOTT
IN A WHEELCHAIR HANDING UP A
LETTER AND THE PRESIDENT AND
KIRBY ARE SAYING WE ARE WELL
AWARE OF THEIR CONCERNS AND WE
DON'T HAVE TO READ IT, HE IS THE
PRESIDENT, HE HAS TO READ THAT
LETTER.
THIS MAN IS THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OF THE STATE OF TEXAS, AND THIS
TRIP IS SUPPOSEDLY ABOUT TRADE
AND ENERGY IN ALL OF THE STUFF,
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS
NATIONAL SECURITY, AND NOBODY
HAS A PLAN FOR THE ENTRANCE OF
ALL THESE DRUGS, HE DOES NOT
EVEN KNOW HOW MANY DRUGS ARE
COMING IN, HE DID NOT EVEN
MENTION THE WORD FENTANYL FOR A
YEAR AND A HALF, DID NOT COME
OFF OF HIS LIPS, BUT THE TRUTH
IS THAT WITH ALL OF THESE GOT A
WAYS, 78,000 AND LIKE THE LAST
COUPLE OF MONTHS, WE DON'T KNOW
WHO IS ON THE TERRORIST LIST, OR
PART OF THE CARTELS, WE DON'T
KNOW WHO IS BUILDING THE ARMORY
THAT THEY ARE USING TO FUNNEL
THE DRUGS THROUGH, AND MEXICO IS
CORRUPT, THE MEXICAN GOVERNMENT
IS CORRUPT, THEY ARE NOT GOING
TO FIND THE CARTELS, AND WE
THINK THAT WE WILL HAVE SOME
REAL AGREEMENT WITH THE CARTELS,
NO, THEY WILL DESTROY US.
>> Jesse: IN THE THREE AMIGOS
ARE SUPPOSED TO TAKE QUESTIONS
FROM ANY MOMENT, WE WILL HAVE
THAT FOR YOU.
I DON'T THINK THE SENATE UNDER
CHUCK SC